hi everyone it's Jerry this is another
group of five puzzles all of them are
endgame positions with white to play and
it's up to you to determine the best
continuation in each case so in this
first puzzle
go ahead pause the video see if you can
find the best continuation for white ok
the solution to puzzle 1 is Bishop to e6
interfering with the Queen's
communication of the bishop if Queen
takes bishop that will result in the
main 3 starting first with Queen f8
after Queen blocks Queen f6 and then
there's maid on g7 if instead of Queen
takes bishop we have the bishop reacting
to the Queen's threat with let's say
Bishop to f5 well now we can make use of
the d4 square in fact any bishop move
would allow Queen to d4 essentially a
mate into Bishop f5 Queen d4 and then
once again there's going to be made on
f6 or g7 and one last tries to maybe do
the d5 advance protecting the bishop but
you'll know II five is now available to
the White Queen and similarly mate is
going to ensue on either f6 or g7 next
so that's the solution to puzzle 1
moving on to the second one okay once
again why to play pause the video see if
you can find the best continuation for
white okay the first move is Knight to
e7 landing a check and if the King makes
use of either f8 or h8 Queen takes
Bishop winning a piece with check
install Queen takes Queen Knight takes
Queen White would just be up a piece and
winning if instead of that Knight takes
Knight well that'll just hang the Queen
the only other try is to take the knight
with the Queen and after Queen takes
Bishop Queen blocks you'll know the
Queen is now in a pin and so black is
now susceptible to the tactic of
deflection Bishop h7 deflecting the King
away from the defense of the Queen Queen
takes Queen and White is winning in this
position so that's the solution to
puzzle 2 moving on to the third one once
again white to play pause the video see
if you can find the best continuation
for white ok the solution to puzzle 3 is
pawn to e5 we
is an interesting move to be making
seeing how that power could be captured
in a couple ways but there is no defense
for black in this position if rook
captures the pawn with check you'll note
the King cannot make use of c6 and now
with this idea of rook to a a
and also just advancing this pawn
there's just too many threats for black
to deal with if the King tries to run
away we could just have rook check on a
eight king f7 in this pawn is going to
be cleaning you'll note that from this
earlier position trying to play to c6 to
deliver mate would just allow the rook
to give checks to the King and so with
this idea in mind if after E 5 and now
the pawn captures here white actually
uses this pawn on e5 as a defense for
their own King King to e6 and now this
rook isn't in a position to check the
white king similarly we have this same
idea going on with rook to e8 giving
check the advancement of the pond as
well so if rook to c2 to try and defend
well that's going to just run into rook
e8 rook black capture the rook and then
play King to e7 this pawn will advance
with check and be just a single square
away from queening white will be winning
in this position as well so that's the
solution to puzzle 3 moving on to the
fourth one once again white to play
pause the video see if you can find the
best continuation for white okay the
best continuation is Queen takes rook a
very forcing move there is only one
legal response and that is to capture
the Queen and now this quiet move Bishop
to c7 and this is of course very
important to do it in this order for
example if you were to capture the Queen
and after the recapture play this Bishop
to c7 move trying to get this move in to
advance the pond it doesn't quite work
because the rook can get there in time
however by playing this Bishop move here
right now after Queen takes Queen by
playing first Bishop to c7 now there's
nothing that could still be done with
this
the queen being pinned to the king and
so if if ruk takes rook we're just going
to have this type of an end game which
is going to be completely winning for
white and if instead be six just looking
to get this King involved in the more
simplified endgame that'll run into rook
takes Queen rook takes rook and after
Bishop to d8 this pawn is not going to
be stopped from queening white is
winning so that's the solution to a
puzzle for in moving on to the last one
once again White's a play pause the
video see if you can find the best
continuation for white okay this one is
actually a mate and four and it's all
very forcing moves starting first with
rook to h8 King to f7 Bishop to ei
landing a check Knight takes bishop is
the only response and after this quiet
move came to g5 there's nothing that
could be done in order to prevent rook
to f8 leading to me this King cannot be
dislodged there are no Knight moves
which would give Czech Bishop moves or
rook moves this King cannot be dislodged
from g5 if after whatever rook to f2
we're just going to have made on f8
really regardless of whatever black does
so that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it and be
sure to let me know how you did by way
of a comment take care bye